White Nights
At your service sir, I'm a level five white knight
Jesus Christ
I'm only like a level three paladin knight squire
if you study what I know you will be able to be on my level
please teach me senpai
Okay, I respect women so much. I
Wish I was one tear to my eye
Let's review the white knight ready by the end of this video
Perhaps you who's watching as well could become a fellow of white knight and protect women all over the planet
Respect woman's this one says George Lopez with a sweet and simple response George Lopez. You should go back to
Mexico
You are bullying and swearing
Who's the white knight here those could be George Lopez
Yeah, I'm confused
Yeah
I think it I think it's people trying to - white knight people and then just be I have it though back in their face
This guy was so proud of this Hillary Clinton me me signed and dated it fools
No, man
Fools no man can defeat me I am no man, Nick Bell
2016 this
That's beautiful Nick Bell twin. So glad I think we should start doing that and all memes
Put it put are totally missing the copyrights. Yeah. Yeah, you gotta put your water marks and all memes
So they know that you originally stole it. Oh Jesus. I thought it was jacksepticeye. Oh
You know only a true white knight can pull up that face
You need to be at least level 10 the face of smugness and at the same time their face you make when oh,
I wasn't wrong. That's literally what it says
your gender is
responsible for the oppression of women for centuries and your race is
responsible for the enslavement of people of color around the globe and your nation is
Responsible for the attempted war of Muslim people were crowned worldwide and you realize it's sorry
They said you pull off their I need to take
Some bad stuff
Just post a selfie either post a selfie
And skip the text. All right, either push the selfie or the text
Okay, do you combine both and I hate you this guy's sitting in first class right now while he's taking the selfie, okay?
Oh, look. It's matpat male feminist. Wondering how long?
Does he have to agree with women until he gets laid?
I can't tell if it has to be satire. I'm also not sure
Jimmy's seafood is savage today. Oh god. I love the company being Savage. Good morning. Peter crab emoji
Ah, childish taunts are good for business. Apparently look, we don't give you hair advice and you won't give us business advice cool. Cool
Yo, yo Jimmy's let's be real for a moment Megan Tara's super rad. So trying to make a joke about her hair is lame a.m
And is 2018 bruh?
2018 can we nuttin can we add chilli nut and they'd just be besties and
For once again, her hair is super rad
Your friend Kip. I cannot stress that enough
Her hair is super rad hashtag BFF, hashtag besties hashtags thirsty
No, she's still not gonna date, you know J Griffith Oh rad effort right a forever. I
can't believe see me Jimmy Seaford came out of winner that one cuz I feel like
taunting PJ so cringy at this point all your girlfriend wants on a
Sunday is for you to take her to brunch while wearing yoga pant a punny t-shirt oversized sunglasses
Her hair in a big effed up bun and for you not to talk to her while she's close to her boat
Look at what a gorgeous mess. He is. You don't deserve her. So be a man
Drive her to brunch
gaze at her adoringly
But keep your freaking mouth shut while she catches up on last night's happenings
Pay the check and maybe she won't figure out she's way out of your league
Jesus Christ
Why do men always have to shop women from scar lanes that too much to ask to look at them dankmemes that being interrupted?
Smh crying shaking my hands so hard right now. Ken shook shook. I'm woke I'm shucking. I'm
Why isn't it called? No woman's sky?
The real question hmm free chicken. Why why is it not come ramming? Sky? Oh, oh
Okay
You made it
Finally I'm ready famous guys
The comments keep excessively harassing her and Twitter will permanently ban you you have been reporting
Kadim male entitlement knows no is the rest of us. Keep going bad. You'll get lead one day
For your thighs legs and breasts
Cindy's is ass to KFC
Your women not a value menu. Yeah
This guy gets it does. He live inside an orange?
You disrespect my lady in the wrong neighborhood Chad
Damn, damn the fedoras. Oh
And that lien? Oh, yeah, the one leg up they bought the bus sounds like a music video
Why did the fedora become such a staple for?
Virginity Brian you dress never worn because it's too big for me fit size 10 to 14. Super stretchy material
20 bucks Leo would smash Leo's about to just get completely
annihilated
Here comes Benjy in though with the save. What exactly do you mean by that?
Are you trying to say that you would have sex with this women? That is growth. Uh-huh
That is gross than the gross way of saying it. Seriously. You're pathetic Ellen
I think you were forgetting Maddie that no, you wouldn't smash this woman is probably so far out of your league. You wouldn't even touch
Facts, I'm not a viewer stalking big deals saying stuff like that
What the most intimate the human contact you receive lately is using the public toilet when the seat is still public done
enjoy your little
PS
Beautiful dress smiley face Sara replies. Hey Jory, you're Benji right back at you. My love o it comes real he's mad
Leo back, okay, excuse me, Ben. I'm sorry. You took my comments serious?
I understand the purpose of your comment was to win female approval at the expense of your dignity. So I'm not particularly offended
Wow, this is I mean, they're both crazy in my opinion now god damn it
Girls are so freakin two-faced and yes, I'm gonna tack her before anybody else. Does it so among my many talents?
I love to bake which I was doing today. He loves to bake. Oh
I thought say it to myself. Hmm, you know would be nice
Making extra muffins and bringing them round two blinks house. No girl's house. Okay. Nope
Nope, apparently not
you are a
You were so rude and ungrateful. Oh
He was gonna make your extra muffins
How could you you didn't even invite me in accept my present which I've gone to extra effort to make
All I want is douchebags not caring for men like me, haha
Don't take it personally
You'll be sweet not very fair posting this on public status and you should be home her instead just giving advice thumbs up
No hate, but if someone does me wrong the last thing I'm good at all
Right your call dude
I can finally call you out on your beers. You came to my house whilst I was with my boyfriend Oh
Which you've known about for ages, but still act like a desperate weirdo trying to get me to go out with you
I don't see how it's to make
Knew you had to be if please a douche and I'm just saying you deserve better, but what do I know? Haha
And just cause someone has a BF doesn't mean another guy can't have a chance with the person
I wasn't trying the guy can still get a chance and swoop in and steal you with with thongs condoms and extra muffins. I
Wasn't trying on my French god damn it. I wasn't trying to be your bf just trying to have a chance you
Surprised the old cupcakes and condoms sweetie didn't work something wrong with that girl. Yeah. I mean the ball friend could have Ward the thong
What a journey
Emotional roller coaster
How the white armor works please hog
'native dissonance helmet allows rad femme dogma to make sense to him. It also corrects his male gaze
That's right eye contact is very important. He's got the magic breastplate that allows him to swallow his pride and check his privilege
Get the soap the soap the SJW sword cuts new entitlement like hot knife through butter
Protective knee pads protects his knees when groveling at the feet of the nearest women while apologizing on behalf of all men
I'm a Jackson my pants. Oh, there it is again
We have now joined we have become what we hated ken what has happened to you. God has come full circle o
Male family speed a
Slight breeze and the old disappeared
It's a male feminist meetup F FEMA comes in. Hey guys, can I join no?
Famine history is the round table meeting. The white knights are here. That's a white knight. It is our duty to
Stand up and respect women worldwide
smash like if you respect women and
for more info on women check out
This is a it was confusing shout out ever received, but thank you. There you go kid